Fox News has it Israel launches second
ground incursion into Gaza Hamas
Commander killed in air strike uh a
bunch of different reports this is all
ma major breaking news us won't draw red
lines for Israel in war with Hamas etc
etc we've got this story from the Daily
Mail quote Hamas will feel our wrath
tonight warns Israel as it unleashes
unprecedented air strikes on Gaza IDF
steps up ground operations and tells
Palestinians to flee South now as
Invasion Looms with phone lines and
internet cut across the city you were
mentioning just a moment ago there
there's a Scott that one of the one of
the uh I guess uh rumors or thoughts or
whatever is that Israel may try to split
the Gaza Strip in half between two
cities tell us what's going on well I
don't really know I have a Israeli
friend that sent me a message earlier
today that said the Invasion has begun
and I don't know the extent of it he
actually had also sent me uh a document
that was um a few years old that was a
military study an Israeli military study
about how to invade and conquer the
strip and they had a few different ideas
about how to go about it and I guess one
of them that my friend who was a a
veteran also he's a veteran of the 2006
Lebanon war um or hez Bala War um he uh
he I think thought that this would be
the most likely
uh take that they would invade kind of
in the middle of Gaza and divide uh
conun from Gaza City and um you know
they have a hell of a fight uh if if
they're really going if the doctrine
truly is to eradicate Hamas as they had
previously said to completely eradicate
Hamas they have a real fight on their
hands because they have thousands of
guys and they have these very deep
tunnels and in
2014 they started to invade and Hamas
guys were popping up out of the ground
out of all over the place and they were
taking casualties they were getting up
close and and kind of um ruining the
Israelis Advantage uh by taking them out
up close and the Israelis they pulled
back and instead just went to artillery
and air power so if they're going to
truly quote unquote clean out the Gaza
Strip of Hamas it's going to cause
incredible casualties on both sides I
just want to mention you know we hear it
from uh Neo lives in the United States
all the time about gun control about if
you want to go up against the US you
need nukes and all that stuff and it's
like dude guys with guns are dangerous
very it's it's you can't occupy a street
corner with a drone you can just
terrorize and devastate but if you want
control of something guys with guns you
know so that that's yeah now Seymour
hirs uh the incredibly important
journalist Seymour hirs has been writing
that he has uh contacts in Israeli
intelligence and in the military and
whatever who are saying that America
America has delivered um these massive
bunker Buster bombs which they're
essentially dropped from very high
altitude and she very high speed and
then they have uh a double charge the
cone fires some kind of superheated
charge into the ground to dig a hole
down 30 40 m and then the main charge
which is also a shape charge that's
shaped downward goes so that you this is
how to kill a bunker without having to
use a nuke is to use these massive
bunker buster bombs and then the idea is
they're going to try to use these to
destroy the Hamas tunnels but of course
Hamas has dug their tunnels deep enough
to try to be protected from those so we
don't know if that'll really work for
them or not they're going to have to do
like tunnel rat type tactics like they
did in Vietnam and one of the things
that that I wanted to that I was
mentioning to Scott earlier that we
didn't want to talk about without being
on air is this is going to be if they do
decide to go into you know really go in
Full full scale it's going to be like
fujia you know in Iraq and that was
bloody and a lot of people died a lot of
innocent people died so the idea that
this is going to be some kind of easy
fight that is absolutely not the case
I'm uh I'm hoping that it's a crazy
thing to Hope but I'm well not really
but I'm hoping that the Ukraine stuff is
fizzling out and that the the but I I'm
not so I'm not so sure right there
there's talk that the US is losing
interest in this because the shifting
fight a shifting fight is better than
expanding into World War III but I got
this for boting feeling as we're
preparing the show reports that us has
led air strikes on Iranian backed
targets already that's another story
we're we'll pull up in a second and I'm
like if the US is deploying tens of
thousands of 19,000 personel into the
region already some are saying that
they've been deploying the largest it's
the largest NATO Fleet ever amassed I
don't know if that's true but I'm seeing
these you know these these these images
and like various individuals in politics
posting these things may or may not be
true but we saw the the we the
announcement last night the US has
deployed uh many more troops into the
region we're getting more moving from
other areas into this area feels like
World War II I have I have uh
information that there are Delta units
being moved into the
area either tomorrow or the day after
something so there are rumors on Twitter
right now that us Elite forces delta
forces are in the conflict already in in
Gaza I don't I I'm I'm hard pressed to
believe well there was a picture last
week of that they put the incompetence
in the White House posted on Instagram a
picture of Biden shaking hands with
Delta Force operators and congratulating
them for all the great work that they're
doing Palestine they took it down real I
believe so no those those guys were
security detail okay they took it down
quickly also but you could when they re
when they reposted it with their faces
blacked out you could still see their
tattoos yeah I mean operational security
there is completely ridiculous but look
as far as World War II I don't know
about you know look there's slippery
slope arguments where Russia ends up
involved here that kind of thing but
look at just the risk of regional War
where we could have you know this war
very quickly never mind how difficult it
is for the people of Gaza and and the
Israeli conscripts who are invading
right now by the way but for the region
this very quickly could escalate to a
war with Hezbollah and Southern Lebanon
with all different
milias in Syria and why are we in Syria
we're in Syria for Israel right Donald
Trump tried to get us out of Syria three
different times and his military
overrode him three different times they
lied to his face and they just cancelled
his orders three times and why because
well because America got rid of Saddam
Hussein and empowered Iran and so now
since the regime change against Assad
failed and Iran and Hezbollah and had
even more influence in Syria than ever
before then America had to stay to
occupy that allom base on the So-Cal to
block the so-called land bridge from
Iran to Beirut and so that's why our
guys are there and then when Israel goes
and does what they're doing in Gaza now
then our guys are at risk and I actually
have a friend whose son is deployed in
Syria right now who's at risk of getting
killed over this you know there's that
guy that ran for congress in help me out
in Washington state that almost won the
Republican K Joe Kent his wife was
killed in Syria after Trump ordered our
guys out and the military said no and
just said that order they said they said
you got it Trump don't do it yeah the
the idea well they made him back down
actually on the or this has happened
three times in 2017 2018 and then in his
lame duck session in December of 2020 he
ordered he said I want our guys out and
they essentially dragged their feet and
then forced him to back down and change
his mind and and look this gets to the
very bottom line right who who listening
to this show right now wants Iraq War 4
right after George W bush uh George W
bush put Iran's best friends in power in
Baghdad who wants to go back to Iraq who
wants to do another war in
Syria supporting Israel is not in the
interests of the United States of
America it's not and general James
Mattis and General David Petraeus both
in candid moments admitted they said
something very close to our men pay a
price in terms of their security in the
Middle East every day because of Israel
and what they do in Palestine and you
talk about fua here's a great example of
that in March of
2004 shik Yasin who was the founder of
Hamas who Israel had financed and helped
for years to grow Hamas he started
moderating his position and trying to
get along so they assassinated him cuz
they don't want a partner for peace
we're going to talk more about that they
murdered him because he was mellowing
out and that was in March of ' 04 was
just like a week later was the giant
riot in fua maybe it's two weeks later
was the giant riot in fuah where the
Blackwater guards were lynched and their
bodies burnt and hung from the cor uh
hung on the bridge and one of the
corpses was dragged through the street
um with another guy tied to the the hood
of a car with a big picture of shik
Yasin in the window and it was the
Israeli assassination of the founder of
Hamas had had helped to touch off that
Riot that killed those Blackwater guards
that then led to Bush and maybe this is
what Mattis was referring to this led to
Bush ordering James Mattis to go in
there and clean them out and what they
did was like a free fire zone if you're
a civilian leave the city if you don't
leave the city your life is forfeit
right like like Vietnam and so they
didn't do that in the other battles in
Iraq War II but they did that in fuah
and that big the first big battle of
fuah in March of' 04 is what really
kicked off the Sunni based Insurgency
that killed 4,000 of our guys in Iraq
war two and it was because Israel
assassinated their own former sock
puppet when he was becoming a public
relations liability for them I wanted to
point out when it came to Biden and the
leaked photo uh Telegraph reports that
it was a hostage Rescue Unit in Israel
yeah that's what I had thought is that I
I don't I don't you guys heard something
different or I think it was security
detail if it's Delta they don't like to
talk about what they're actually doing
well that was the Scandal the Scandal
was they leaked the information on
accident they weren't supp on their
Instagram yeah and that's how they
deleted it Delta Delta is top tier
Special Operations forces when they get
killed they don't report their
casualties right this is these guys are
clandestine forces top guys right above
the the special forces and so but
they're there in
Israel that I I think I don't know if
they're going to I don't know if they're
going to put him into Israel and I this
is this is only like hearsay stuff that
I that I've I've got but it's my
understanding that they're probably
going to be going into the bases in
because there's there's a base in the
desert in Iraq that they that they
forward operate from so they can get
into Syria and stuff so if I understand
correctly they're going to be in that
area don't know that they won't put them
in in support uh roles with the for the
IDF uh I think that more than likely if
there's a support Force it'd be the the
two Marine Expeditionary units that are
in the area that are on uh carriers um
you know Delta doesn't have enough guys
where they'd be a big support role
they're usually the the because there's
only a few hundred of them there's maybe
like 500 Delta the post said that they
have generals embedded with the Israeli
military helping advis that could be I'm
not sure which service advising is sure
like we can have an argument like why
are we involved but actual Warriors
actual Fighters down there that that's
disconcerting and I would also be very
uh concerned about the kind of person
that gleefully Smiles with excitement at
meeting Joe Biden yeah seriously no but
but for real I mean look if you talk to
the average American they don't like Joe
Biden no not you you you will find your
average Democrat who despises Donald
Trump with the most extreme Trump
derangement syndrome does not like Joe
Biden but they'll still vote for him and
that I get that's fine my point is they
don't meet Joe Biden go yeah fist bumb
high five black it's so great to meet
you and I look at this photo of these
guys shaking Biden's hand and I'm like I
worried about although you know I mean
they're military and he's the president
that's basically
all you know it's his approval rating is
down 11 points among Democrats right now
but this this is my point the idea that
there are people who are like I'm
excited to meet him he's the boss hurah
and it's just like dude Biden's an evil
evil guy like you should be like I am
you should be ashamed that he is the one
giving orders agree but I think perhaps
for a lot of these guys that are doing
the top tiered stuff they don't think
Joe Biden's the boss they well I mean
the D those like just because the
picture they they were smiling like I
don't think that I think it's likely
that they were putting a face on because
you don't spit in the face of the
president I would be I would be
magnanimous if I met the president I
would say that it was a I would be kind
and smile as well you know my my bigger
concern is the excitement to meet him
and get a photo up and do all these
things instead of being like look I
get's the president I'll be respectful
there's a difference yeah I I I'm I'm
fairly confident I can't say for sure
but I'm I'm fairly confident that they
were getting ribbed later on the dudes
were like really cuz there are people
that I know that are that are like not
in the military that also know dudes
that are like like that and they're just
like yeah those they they weren't well
look I want to go back to what you're
saying about like you know how could any
of them have faith in him as their
commander-in-chief remember in 2013
Barack Obama tried to take us to war in
Syria over the first fake sarin attack
and essentially the American Military
and and any potential volunteers were
like no we're not falling Barack Obama
into battle that's our commander-in
chief forget it well look if Barack
Obama was JFK then Joe Biden's LBJ who
has faith in him like no one you're
going to sign your son up for the
service when Joe Biden's the one calling
the shots let's if you're already on the
Delta team I guess you might not quit
but who wants to send their son to join
the service right now let's go back in
time let's uh yeah so we have this
period under Barack Obama oh boy did I
fall for that one in uh 2008 I had all
my friends being like he's going to end
these wars man we we all hate the wars
we all hate what George W Bush was doing
and I was like all right whatever I
guess we'll vote for the guy and then
Barack Obama gets in and like day three
he's like I'm gonna blow some Gibs up
got to blow them up too many of them and
then we like I remember one of the first
too many of them that's Sheamus joke
Sheamus shout out Sheamus
got to blow them up too many and uh when
it's like day three of his presidency in
Pakistan yeah it was it was like 23
women and children were killed in a
village in in an air strike or whatever
and I was just like that was the wedding
right wasn't it a wedding I'm not it's
been a long time there were a lot of
weddings I don't think that particular
one was but that one sticked with me
Pakistan civilians killed and I said
whoa whoa whoa whoaa hold on hold on
hold on he's there now Obama was
supposed to say no and then oh boy did I
learn quick how old was I 2008 and I was
just like well that was fun I'm out I
was like 18 in that election I remember
cuz I was in New York doing like Indie
art projects and everyone was very on
board with Obama and I remember telling
them like he promised that he was going
to send more troops to Afghanistan and
they were like no he didn't and I was
like no he totally said he was going to
send more guys to Afghanistan which I
can't vote for him because of that
because he's you know my goal is to vote
anti-war and they were like well he's
not going to do that and then of course
he did that these were also the same
people who when he put the Obamacare
into place that had a mandate and if you
didn't sign up for health insurance you
would get taxed extra they were like
that's great and then when they got
taxed extra they were like why me
seriously it's partisanship is the mind
killer it's the worst and you're right
he out vly said he was going to escalate
the Afghan war although and I write
about this I got I got a chapter two on
this in Fool's a and what he really said
he wanted to send a couple brigades
which was mostly just like a PR thing
that he was saying Afghanistan is the
good War Iraq is the bad War whatever
then as soon as he got into power they
just absolutely rolled him and it was
the Secretary of Defense the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs of Staff generals
Petraeus and mccristal in Alliance with
McCain and Graham in the Senate and they
spent nine months pressuring him to
escalate that war by 70,000 troops which
eventually he did and and lindsy Graham
promised him he said give us a number
this is after he already sent 40 Graham
said give us us being him and McCain
give us a number that starts with a
three and we'll leave you alone meaning
30,000 something more troops and Obama
made the deal so here was his
calculation right I'm gonna I'm going to
Triple A war that I know I can't win I
know that I'm going to get thousands of
American soldiers shot and blown up and
killed I know I'm going to get tens or
hundreds of thousands of Afghans killed
but it's going to keep John McCain off
my back we made a deal and and that was
what he did and so he escalated the war
and lost it anyway Lindsey Graham is
vile evil you saw what he just said
recently right yeah with or without
evidence it's time to start bombing
Iranian Targets in he wants to go to war
with Iran so bad and it I know that
there are still like holdovers in the in
the government that still think it's a
good idea I don't think that there is
anyone in America that thinks it's a
good idea no regular people in America
that think it's a good idea to engage in
a war with Iran right look in 2007 Dick
Cheney and George Bush wanted to they
they were escalating the war they
launched the the Iraq War Surge and then
they even dropped the lies about the
nuclear weapons program for a minute to
focus on the lies that they claimed and
people should check this it's not true
and I wrote it all up in enough already
they claimed that Iran was responsible
for every roadside bomb that went off in
Shiite parts of Iraq that's just not
true they were all being made in Iraq by
Iraqis but that was the propaganda and
that was supposed to be the excuse for
the war and then what happened was was
the The Joint Chiefs brought George W
bush to the Pentagon and I believe this
is in January or February of 2007 and
they went to the tank like the secure
room in the basement or whatever and
they told W bush we're not going to Iran
like maybe the Air Force and the Navy
talk tough with their air power but the
Army and the Marines who are already
getting chewed up in Iraq and
Afghanistan and the Special Operations
forces they will die by the thousands
and thousands and maybe tens of
thousands in a war because you have to
send in to to take out the anti-aircraft
you have to send in Special Operations
forces with laser designators to take
out the anti-aircraft and you sure can't
win a war or get a real regime change
from the air all you could do is some
kind of crazy punitive strike anyway
right and as they put it you guys with
guns they said that's right we do not
have strategic uh I forgot the word for
it what was it the Strategic Domin
that's not the term for it I'm sorry um
I believe it was I'm sorry anyway the
point was the Pentagon they want to be
able to um oh escalation dominance
pardon me this was the term I'm looking
for we we don't want to fight unless we
have escalation dominance meaning we
control every stage of the war so when
we do this they'll do that but don't
worry because then we'll do this and
then they'll do that and but we have
that covered and they said but in the
case of Iran we do not have escalation
dominance in the case of Iran if we
attack Iran they have tens of thousands
of missiles now luckily we don't have
100,000 troops in Iraq and Afghanistan
any anymore but we got tens of thousands
in Kuwait we still do have thousands in
Iraq low thousands in Iraq and we have
the fifth Fleet navy base at Bahrain and
we have centcom headquarters at the AL
ulid base in Cutter and our allies the
Saudis Bahrain UAE have trillions of
dollars worth of economic targets all up
and down the western side of that Gulf
and if we go to war with Iran every bit
of that is up for grabs including our
Navy and Air Base there a geography
lesson would wake a lot of Americans up
very quickly so you can pull this up
this is Google Maps figure it out as
soon as you look at the map you go now I
get it Iraq
Afghanistan two amazing uh coincidental
countries for the US Sig with a bunch of
military bases in and Kuwait where we
have a bunch of troops I wonder why that
may be and what do you think Iran is
thinking surrounded by us milit Ary
assets this has been the plan for a long
time in fact Jen yuger mentioned um
Wesley Clark was that his name yes who
talked about the Seven Nations the US
was wanted to to invade and and uh
Iran's one of them have we has has the
US gone after all of them already or or
which ones almost okay all right so it's
a great anecdote people who aren't
familiar you ought to look this up it's
General Wesley Clark he was the guy that
did the Kosovo War for Bill Clinton he
was the Supreme Allied Commander of NATO
in 1999 uh almost got us all killed in a
in World War III there ask me about that
anecdote later but anyway uh and this
gets right to the neocons and the Israel
Lobby in the United States um he went to
the Pentagon right after September 11th
and an officer said General come here I
want to show you something and showed
him this piece of paper he said this is
the plan for a regime change in the new
war he said we're going to war with Iraq
and Wesley Clark said Iraq why would we
go to Iraq they don't have anything to
do with September 11th or alqaeda of
course and the guy said yeah no check it
out so the list was I hope I can get
this right the list was Iraq Lebanon by
which they meant not necessarily
everyone in Beirut but hez Bala in
Lebanon Syria Libya
Somalia and did I already say Sudan and
Iran ending with Iran well they got they
did Iraq War II they failed to do the
regime change in Syria they did Libya
they broke off the south from
Sudan um and you know there was a regime
change there although I don't know if
there was America sock puppets really
that took over or not they certainly
broke the country in half and so the
only one left um is uh well and and hez
Bala still stands yeah and then is Iran
and so look this gets to all of a rock
word too let's talk about the clean
break have you ever read the paper a
clean break have you ever heard of that
okay so um David wormser is an important
neoconservative appara he was foreign
policy adviser to Dick Cheney in the W
bush uh first W bush term and in 1996
when benjaman Netanyahu was brand new
the first the first time he was the
Prime Minister of Israel he came in in
96 and David wormser Douglas FEI and
Richard Pearl wrote this study these are
American neoconservatives it's called a
clean break a new strategy for securing
the realm and they wrote it for
Netanyahu and what it says is this it
says
Iran Syria and
Hezbollah are the threat to Israel
particularly hez Bala in southern
Lebanon backed by Iran and Syria and
what we want to do is we want to break
that
chain and then get this they said to
break that chain what we want to do is
we want to get rid of Saddam Hussein in
Iraq huh Saddam Hussein is the Sunni the
minority Sunni dictator sitting on a
super majority Shiite
population and Iran and hezb of course
are these fundamentalist Shiite regimes
so why does it make sense to these
neocons to get rid of Saddam Hussein
well it was this ridiculous rub Goldberg
scheme that they had come up with if we
get rid of Saddam say who's rub Goldberg
oh rub Goldberg is the guy that makes
the ridiculous like the mouse trap
machine it's like 100 little gear turn
to make yeah PE her's breakfast extion
machine that's exactly right PE Herman's
breakfast that's probably a lot of young
people somea what yeah y'all y'all get
the peewee's Big Adventure Off The
Pirate Bay tonight it's it's a classic
it's a great I think it's on probably on
Netflix must be but look so so here was
the scheme okay The rubbe Goldberg
scheme was if we get rid of Saddam
Hussein then we will get the cousin of
the King of Jordan to take over Iraq and
because he's a hashemite with the blood
of the prophet in his veins all the
Shiites will just bend over and kiss his
bottom and do whatever he says which
this is completely crazy the Shiites
don't rever the hashemites at all the
hashimites are sunnis and even though
the Shiites Revere the bloodline of the
Prophet it's not like they're priests
and even priest and Cardinals and
Bishops don't have like political
control over their people directly so in
other words they were living in this
fantasy world that the Shiites of Iraq
would become compliant under the new
pro-american installed and pro-israeli
installed regime and then because Shiite
Islam is born in Iraq and then spread
into Iran they would get the Shiite
clergy in Naj to order hez Bala to stop
being friends with Iran and start being
friends with Israel and and Iraq under
these compliant Shiites would then give
the full advantage to America Jordan
Turkey and Israel our friends in the
region against Iran well Tim this is the
dumbest damn thing this makes no sense
at all and and people can read it's
called a clean break by wormser the
followup is called coping with crumbling
States and if you really want to know
they wrote a book about it called teing
Ally and then what really happened in
Iraq War II what happened in Iraq War II
was Bush overthrew the minority Sunni
dictator and he put the super majority
Shiite population in charge and their
political factions who happened to be
guys who'd been living in Iran for 30
years since Jimmy Carter had hired
Saddam Hussein to invade Iran back after
the Revolution and so they were the ones
who came and inherited the whole thing
so when we think about Iraq War II of
the George W bush years that whole 5
years Civil War that was going on that
was Bush fighting for Iran's side in the
war against his own friends because that
was what the neoconservatives thought
would be good for Israel thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net